voicemail two one nine two david p here
is a voicemail from someone who is not
particularly thrilled with the way the
show is going you to her home wolf
flakes makes it sticky in the army maybe
even get some transgender surgery done
idiots yeah okay well that how do you
even react to that i thought at first he
was going to say that we should be put
in the army so he can be toughened up a
bit oh yeah man up his joke doesn't
really make sense though because
transgenders won't be allowed in trumps
military yeah none of it makes sense
no i think that's really the bottom line
none of it makes sense on today's bonus
show Sheriff David Clarke was apparently
in talks for a trump White House job
when new chief of staff John Kelly said
yeah not gonna happen the Zika virus is
being used to treat aggressive brain
cancer and a descendant of robert e lee
quits his pastor position over the
hurtful reaction to his appearance on
mtv all of those stories and more on the
bonus show starting tomorrow you can
access the bonus show not only through
membership but also through patreon
check it out